hey you guys it's max with max tech a
few months ago when the brand-new s10
plus and s10 devices were launched we
ditched has tried to hack this phones
ultrasonic fingerprint scanner and in
that video we were not successful in
doing so
but Samsung has also made some changes
with their software that has made the
scanner better my biggest question is
has Samsung reduced the security in
order to make the overall experience
better so we are back at it again to
test out the sn+ ultrasonic fingerprint
scanner and right here I have a
fingerprint copy that is made with just
Elmer's glue this is actually very easy
to do all you need is a hot glue gun
some Elmer's glue a little bit of cold
water you make a fingerprint fill it in
and then you have a copy of course it's
not going to be that simple to go and
copy somebody's fingerprints but if
somebody's determined they definitely
will be able to pull this off and it did
work for the oneplus 60 now once you
have it dried you actually just peel up
and remove your copy there you go in
this s10 plus but even actually
registered his fingers he has multiple
registered just like a lot of our
viewers and commenters have mentioned
just like I had and same thing with Lou
from unbox therapy and just to show you
guys you can see that my fingerprints do
not work on this phone
but even come and show us that your
fingerprint is registered so working
here there you go this is already
there's just Samsung fingerprint scanner
trying to get
there we go it's working and mine do not
work here my thumb is doing nothing
let's grab our copy we have the moment
of truth here ok is even reading it no
match
what is this Bixby
come on Bixby hey we got into the we got
into it yeah invoke big speak from our
thumbprint let's try that again
remember in the past this did not work
at all
it would not let us in no matter what we
did ok it's not even reading it
there we go you guys saw that right
thicker wow that is working just as
reliably as your regular fingerprint
which isn't each time but it's actually
it's actually working each time right
that got me in now let's try my
thumbprint it's not working and try our
copy once again the biggest question
that I have now is am i able to login
because we have multiple fingerprints
registered in order to get it working
faster and more reliably or because of
the changes that Samsung has made with
their software updates so let's login
with our fake fingerprint here ok let's
go into the settings I'm going to remove
the extra fingerprints ok
let's delete all of these
[Music]
but II was gonna add in his fingerprint
once again so you guys know we have zero
fingerprints registered out of the other
than his here let's see what happens
okay it's not working I was not
expecting that honestly I am very
shocked and surprised I wasn't expecting
that and just to show you guys that
there's no shenanigans going on we just
have one fingerprint in the one Vadim
added let's go ahead and close it up
here and you guys can see that all in
one shot our one shot is feeling there
we go we got in so as you see it still
takes multiple attempts you can't just
get in on the first time every time like
if you have multiple fingerprints but
you can get in as you guys can see with
just one finger for added I'm still
getting in now pretty much every time as
long as I remember the proper position
it's kind of getting in every single
time
BAM and just to prove it to you guys
look I don't have my fingerprint is not
registered
we'll grab this guy again we are in
and then if we go to biometrics we just
have one fingerprint add it into there
all right gay so you saw it for yourself
two months after the release of the s10
and s10 plus where we were able to hack
it with all these software updates now
we are able to hack it Samsung did lower
the security or how accurate has to be
in order to get in to improve the
usability of this phone and I know a ton
of you guys out there including myself
add multiple fingerprints to get it to
be more reliable and more consistent
which does help but as you saw once you
do that that actually also reduces the
security for the average person it
probably doesn't matter at all but if
you're somebody who really cares about
their security if you have important
files on here if you're an executive if
you need to make sure it's secure don't
put in multiple fingerprints and maybe
you know have a different password now
if you have to leave the software or
don't use the fingerprint scanner if it
matters a ton if you just have one
fingerprint it's a lot more secure but
it could still be hacked now if you guys
haven't seen it yet we also tested out
the brand-new one plus seven pros
optical fingerprint scanner and the
results there we're a very very
interesting if you want to check out
that video you guys can click it right
over here make sure to click that circle
above to subscribe and enable
notifications to see more videos like
this one this has been max with max tech
and I'll see you in the next video